you talked earlier about asking uh just
to flip that sample initially right and
then do it connie ended up doing it
obviously just always had like a
snapping kind of thing shout out to jess
uh
he's my brother but i'll be heating him
up i'm just curious like what what you
know you were there during the blueprint
sessions like
i bought the beats that's why i was
gonna ask you like kanye kanye talking
about just kind of cop being a copycat i
don't get into that [ __ ] but you know i
just know that both just blaze and con
and kanye came through hip hop and he
brought me both of these beats
the reason why i like what's going on is
because really what happened with kanye
was the first
record
song single that came out on rockefeller
with a kanye beat was the truth
seagull's the truth yeah so you know
that was like the beginning of it all
and then he had all this beat tape
and i just brought it to jay and he just
had this bank mega [ __ ] you know what i
mean
but it was hip-hop that brought those
two
and then same exact time i remember like
his hip-hop's quiet so he's not the kind
of he's like you have to like trigger
him to know what's going on with him
right and i remember just being like yo
what the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like it was like that with rock the mic
like right i was like what's the state
property records and [ __ ] and i was like
listen i was like hold on you buck put
this [ __ ] out i'm a director put it up
you know he's just quiet
but he's a genius they're all geniuses